let's move on to the crypto Corner yeah
crypto as we all know
is taking over it's taken over Society
it's taken over Fortune 500 companies
big banks are getting involved in crypto
and now sports in America is getting
taken over by crypto did you hear what
happened in La David no tell me no oh my
God
do you know where the Lakers played you
know where the Clippers played you know
the LA Kings play Staple Center they did
play at the Staples Center now pardon me
in the next month
the Staples Center will now be named no
the crypto.com arena
that is Davis just walked off the show
he is pissed no cause you didn't say we
were going to talk about that
[Laughter]
uh you have the link David sorry let's
shook it right now so for the last 20
years since 1999 so 21 plus years
crypto.com the Lakers
in LA Clippers as well I think they're
getting their own Arena too yeah
um and the LA Kings for our hockey fan
so they have played at a place called
the Staples Center bonus points for
where they played before the Staples
Center bonus points before the Staples
no no clue they played at the Great
Western Forum where Mike uh Michael
where Magic Johnson used to ball out the
Forum the floor okay there it was so if
you ever watch those so now the Staples
Center is going to be renamed the
crypto.com arena so this is the richest
the richest naming rights deal
in sports history
700 million dollars do 700 divided by 20
real quick uh the naming the the 20-year
naming rights agreement makes the
singapore-based crypto.com the official
cryptocurrency platform of the LA Lakers
and the LA Kings 100 million divided by
20. 12. yes yes 12 by 20 by 20 sorry 35
million 35 million bucks a year is what
they're paying
bingo bango it's funny to crypto.com it
sounds like what an old person how an
old person would try to learn about
Bitcoin yeah what do I do just go to
crypto.com
that sounds like a joke dude sounds like
a joke it's a 700 million dollar joke
right it's like not a joke at all not a
joke at all they are taking over the
richest naming rights deal that's like
one of my graduates history 700 million
our friend David over here did the math
700 divided by 20 35 million bucks a
year I'm wondering if they're paying
that in cash or in Bitcoin so you know
how much
uh the Staple Center 20 years ago when
they did their deal they signed for 20
years 1999 so a little over 20. they
paid 120 million
okay wow 100 to 120 divided by
20. uh so they they got the naming
rights in 1999 six it's six million
dollars a year so six million 20 years
later is now 35 million dollars a year
real estate that has appreciated that is
appreciated that Staples Center is now
the crypto.com center and just like
perfect timing perfect timing the name
change will take place on Christmas day
December 25th while the LA Lakers take
on the Brooklyn Nets so during that game
Christmas Day biggest day in the NBA all
in the finals biggest game all the
building exactly biggest games
crypto.com coming to you live from the
crypto.com arena let's hear your
announcer boys who wants to do it coming
to you live from the crypto.com arena
the Lakers
yes yes there it was so now uh Jeff have
you heard of this crypto stuff Jeff no I
have heard of it James uh it does seem
to be some sort of Witchcraft I do think
so as well I think it is witchcraft
let's focus on the game there goes
LeBron James so you know LeBron's going
to get involved in this oh he's going to
be playing at crypto.com you don't think
they're gonna have a little LeBron I
don't know I've never come out I've
never seen LeBron in a Staples
commercial you know what I mean I don't
know how close these people are to this
well because Staples ain't exactly that
cool yeah yeah crypto.com is yeah let's
talk about how uncool Staples is little
takeaways for you whether you like it or
not crypto's coming into your life
whether you like it or not it's coming
to you I don't like crypto I live in LA
I'm not messing with crypto uh where's
the game tonight crypto.com Arena [ __ ]
there it is okay I can't escape it yeah
I mean that bubble is closing Big Time
Heat fan love Miami Heat my dad took me
there since 1988 when I was a little
little young boy to sit on his lap at
the game now the American Airlines Arena
is now the FTX Arena Yeah a different
competing crypto exchange to crypto.com
FTX owned by billionaire 29 year old Sam
bankman freed uh
absolute genius so Miami used to be
American Airlines now the FTX Arena La
used to be the Staple Center soon to
become crypto.com MLB have you not seen
FTX all over what the World Series FTX
was everywhere okay Premier League
you're you're a soccer guy yeah do you
not see what etoro all over Tottenham
and Southampton and Newcastle these
teams yeah nuts
yeah okay but now change Stamford Bridge
to the goddamn ethereum Stadium that's
the day football died
but it's common man so you talk you
talked joked about Staples you never saw
LeBron in a Staples commercial a little
a little fact checking on Staples
obviously they're known for office
supplies school supplies pens and uh
folders
it's a stapler it's a stapler for all my
friends out that's my favorite Spanish
word by the way they've been a
struggling company it probably wasn't
the best investment for them to to
invest
into the Staples Center 20 years ago 20
years ago I'm telling you right now
since 2017 they went from a public
company to a private company they got
sold yeah they're struggling their
numbers have been going down Staples is
the best crypto is the future Staples
American Airlines I mean they're
replacing a lot of big companies that
have been around for a very long time
I'm no expert but I might put some money
in crypto now huh I mean it does seem to
be a received yeah that's what I'm
saying that's with all these stories
like it's legitimizing Bitcoin yeah
Bitcoin cannot be more we're there we're
there yeah it's all right people have
been second guessing
all we talk is money if you enjoyed that
short clip from the sawscast click here
to watch another click here to watch the
full episode or just stay bro
foreign